hôpital Félix Guyon
le premier hôpital moderne de la Réunion
est inauguré en 1904 au camp Ozou non
loin des quartiers populaires de la
ville les plus touchés par le paludisme
afin de limiter la propagation des virus
l'ingénieur Laniel conçoit une vingtaine
de pavillons répartis le long d'une
année centrale selon leur statut social
les passions occupent des bâtiments plus
ou moins confortables les plus aisés se
trouvent à proximité de la rue les plus
pauvres en font de parcelles près de la
morgue non loin du rempart
accessible via un grand porche en
basalte la rue intérieure dessert un
ensemble de constructions au style
architectural extrêmement variés
cette grande diversité a été rendue
possible notamment grâce à l'apport
d'une importante innovation les pierres
artificielles conçues à l'aide de moules
ancêtre du bloc et autres parpaings
cette technique utilisée pour la
première fois sur ce chantier public va
se généraliser à la Réunion dans la
seconde moitié du 20e siècle
des plus beaux édifices du site et celui
réservé aux patients de première
catégorie ce vaste bâtiment étage
dispose notamment de varangues dotés
d'éléguents garde-corps en fonte d'art
fermé en 1957 suite au transfert de ses
services au centre hospitalier de
Bellepierre cet hôpital baptisé Félix
Guyon en hommage au célèbre urologue
réunionnais est aujourd'hui désaffecté
reflet des théories des médecins du 19e
siècle sur l'hygiène et la santé il est
cependant protégé depuis l'an 2000 au
titre des Monuments Historiques